I usually never share this but I will
today glean the rock Johnson revealing
intimate personal details that's right
the Jumanji star jumped on a scale for
all his Instagram followers to see he
even shared the result 270 pounds laying
lean his men alive machine lot of cheese
on that pizza
Johnson's weighty revelation with part
of his Monday motivation post where he
gave fans an inside look at it's 5:00
a.m. routine I like to get into the gym
when I can before the Sun comes up it
helps me anchor my day and you know
there's a method to the madness that the
rock requires three bottles of water per
workout and likes to kick off the week
training legs he also revealed this
never sure what I write on the
chalkboard but I'm gonna do it now since
it's Monday all right so this is what I
wrote I do anything like I do everything
with all I got like the actor really
means any motivation his health and
fitness is a regular topic of
conversation in almost every et
interview you know you're you're big
you're rich you're tough but I tell you
what you rip off that cast in the movie
and it is something else now it's Wayne
yes so you have a cast in the movie
instead of getting it sawed off like a
normal person I just break it off
because I am indeed and daddy in fact
has to go to work
I left the gym I love everybody in it
yeah fitness health and fitness gyms the
hardest john cena man he's a bad dude
he's incredibly strong yeah he's amazing
he gyms the hardest you have a date with
it's just your arms day I heard right
that just one day I have an arms a chest
day next day oh my god it next day all
right
[Music]
[Music]